so I started out you know like a normal
kid in high school I used to just smoke
regular flour weed with my buddies and
then one of my friends introduced me to
a dab rig and it would get to the point
where I was having to smoke that pan
like every 30 minutes in order to keep
the high up
concerns about marijuana used to be the
stuff of Reefer Madness but in Colorado
already a decade into legalization High
potency products are birthing new
critics we've had legalization here now
for a long time and it is just wreaked
havoc on a generation of our kids
despite the millions in marijuana tax
revenue some residents feel there have
been unintended consequences the
youngest kid I've seen that's addicted
to pot is seven it doesn't matter what
kind of parent you are cannabis in our
community is everywhere for a child it's
as simple as going on to Snapchat
finding out where they're dealing and
going and getting it
thank you
Karen Randall is a doctor at a large
Hospital in Pueblo Colorado sometimes
touted as the Napa Valley of pot the
former steel Town invited the marijuana
industry in to try and boost the city
According to some residents it hasn't
worked out quite like that here it is
it's like in all its Glory the Napa
Valley of cannabis yeah that's what the
Napa Valley looks like
a study in Colorado found marijuana
related calls to poison control centers
more than doubled around the time
Recreational Products hit the market in
2014. a separate study showed vomiting
related cases in the state also Rose 29
from 2013 to 2018. one of the big ones
that we see every single day is what we
call scrombading and it's a combination
of screaming and vomiting is really kind
of peculiar to cannabis alone
oh
foreign
I would be vomiting like often I used to
weigh like 150 pounds I got to the point
where I was weighing 117 pounds so I
went to my psychiatrist he actually did
a scope to see if I had like gallbladder
cancer or something which I didn't and
there was no nothing wrong with my GI
tract he asked me do you substance and I
said yeah I use marijuana he told me
that you can use too much to the point
to where it's called cannabis
hyperemesis disorder which is where I
was at Dr Jesse Hinckley of the
University of Colorado first became
concerned about cannabis after seeing
some youth admitted to inpatient
Psychiatry these were youth typically
without any sort of previous psychiatric
history who were presenting acutely
psychotic so hearing voices seeing
things paranoid delusional and pretty
abrupt onset typically after a period of
heavy cannabis use of more than 4 000
marijuana related visits to emergency
rooms or urgent care in Colorado five
percent were diagnosed with
schizophrenia or psychosis that's
compared to less than one percent among
the general U.S population most people
don't even know what's for sale in
dispensaries like do you know what
dabbing is or shatter and they make them
in flavors that are appealing to kids
Scooby sacks flavored Girl Scout cookie
birthday cake flavored Dawn reinfeld
helped form the group blue rising to
advocate for gun control but they've
turned their attention toward reforming
marijuana laws the very same laws that
some of them voted for look if we want
to say that you need to follow the
science on climate
the science on high potency THC but
following the science isn't as easy as
it seems there's no consensus on what
level of THC makes the product High
potency the market is also flooded with
synthetic variations confusing matters
further it's a humble sour raw flour
usually starts at 20 THC or higher up
steeply from the four percent levels of
yesteryear what are the facts about
marijuana concentrated products like
Vape rarely start below 60 percent many
extracts like dab wax and shatter go
above 90.
it was my birthday party actually so I
took a dab and that was about 75 THC the
first time and then eventually I found
out that I could just get the dab pen
which would last me longer I'd turn be
cheaper so two years of just daily use
at 98 THC
recreational marijuana is legal in 23
States but remains illegal under federal
law the U.S government is gathering data
towards a pledge to reconsider
legalizing by the end of 2023 while
Germany is also drafting regulations to
start recreational use I asked our
Hospital how much it would cost just to
see a patient get IV fluids and some
medicines it would be about five to six
thousand dollars for a ER visit we see
at least one a day so if you go okay
that's five thousand dollars times
365 days that's 1.8 million dollars and
then if you times it by 25 years in
Colorado
that's millions of dollars spent on just
the size
treatment for America's drug habit often
comes down to mental health care which
sometimes isn't covered by private
insurance many such patients rely on
Medicaid we're just cost shifting right
they're taking money in and we're cost
shifting their medical care to the
general public if you look at the trends
and the numbers not only did cannabis go
up in the industry we'll say well of
course it went up because now it's legal
and everybody's using but
methamphetamines went up cocaine went up
opiates went up and my test doesn't test
for fentanyl of course fentanyl's gone
up we're reaching the number record
number of deaths in January 2022
Colorado started using a tracking system
The Limited daily THC concentrates per
customer the compromise reached by
legislators blue Rising doctors and the
local cannabis industry had immediate
impact medical marijuana sales fell
about 7 million overall marijuana sales
also contracted falling about 44 below
their peak of 202 26 million in 2020.
you know it's legal here it's going to
stay legal but how can we have a
regulatory framework that protects
public health for the legal marijuana
industry the stakes are high this year
in the U.S more than a third of the 34
billion in expected cannabis sales will
come from products with high levels of
THC the U.S cannabis Council says
millions of Americans regularly consume
marijuana products without any issues
confusingly some Studies have shown that
marijuana can have both beneficial and
detrimental effects on some mental
health conditions but the industry can't
deny that the legal Market has created a
new breed of supercharged products I
honestly believe that if we had left
cannabis but the previous potency if
they had left it at two to three percent
we probably wouldn't be talking
foreign
[Music]